the three funniest moments from Kim
Kardashian's interview with superfan
Jennifer Lawrence Plus Taylor Swift's
happy new single I think she's in love
hello and happy Friday friends i'm denny
direct oh and this is the daily denny
and allow I love alliteration all right
speaking of do you guys catch Kim
Kardashian last night on Jimmy Kimmel
Kim gave one what I think is one of her
best interviews ever thanks to Jennifer
Lawrence who has made it very clear how
obsessed she is with the Kardashians
last night she filled in for Kimmel and
wasted no time getting down to business
do you think it's a coincidence that
Reggie Bush's wife looks just like you
maybe if you can believe it that's not
even the best part here are three of the
best moments from their chat and proof
Jennifer needs her own late night show
number one the time JLo got very comfy
in kris Jenner's closet but you said I'm
not joking I really want Kanye to style
me and so I said okay and then I come
back in and you're fully butt-naked and
we put on one of my mom's dresses and
you wore it throughout the whole dinner
oh it's I have it in it
Kim also revealed she once caught that
cheating on her on her birthday
it was that dinner with all of my best
friends put it on speaker board
wondering like where my boyfriend was
his voicemails he was flying in town to
meet another girl on my birthday and
lied to me that he was in a different
City
oh my god that got the Taylor Swift song
yo profs is a law for sneaking in a
mention of Kim and Kanye's frenemy
t-swift
she also asked what everybody wants to
know okay so what do you guys like think
about blac Chyna you know I was I always
said when someone was gonna ask me you
know dream is gonna see this one day and
so I think it's just super respectful to
just not say anything about you know my
niece's mom can we talk about how Kim is
probably more civilized than a friggin
Academy Award winner and I love
everything about that now for the most
part though Kim was more of an open book
last night then her mom was on Ellen
today take a look but you have lots of
pregnant children right now you do you
have a whole bunch of them oh here I
could feel where this is going no not
not trying to trick me you know
confirming pregnancies well you're
waiting for your show to do it I know
that but I'm just going to say you know
I get 10% dings still nothing Chris not
even with Ellen y'all are really
spreading out that five season deal I
mean while Kendall Jenner was busy
ringing in her 22nd birthday with
rumored boyfriend Blake Griffin the two
were snapped separately
heading into West Hollywood hotspot
petite back idea and eye witness tells
et that Blake and Kendall were having
the most fun all smiles and Dancing with
all the company now the small guest list
included Haley Baldwin Kris Jenner
Caitlyn Jenner Kim and Kanye as well as
Kourtney and her boyfriend jonas benji
bob who shared this shot of the birthday
girl on instagram stories now by the way
in case you were wondering how much
Kendall's sparkly thigh-high boots cost
those retails were about a cool ten
thousand dollars which explains why she
could not afford the rest of her shirt
right but moving on now to my favorite
part of the week new music Friday not
sure if you guys heard but a new
up-and-comer just dropped her latest
single Taylor Swift have you heard of
her
both hey just gave Fant fans another
glimpse into her upcoming album
reputation with her latest track call it
what you want
like a daydream walking with his head
down I'm the monies back into my babies
fly like a jet stream high above the
scene loves me like I'm dead no no this
girl is in love I'm gonna take a stab in
the darkness she's talking about rumored
boyfriend Joe all in here but gotta say
I'm kind of missing the Faro retailer
but look what you made me do
I need the Tiki swim alright meanwhile
Sam Smith's long anticipated second
album the thrill of it all is out today
and yes he's still bringing the feels
and here's the proof this is Bernie
[Music]
very
[Music]
so too
it's my name
No
to pay for the
[Music]
I'm so happy and also emotional that Sam
Smith is back but that's all I've got
for you guys today because I need a pat
that's right we are taking daily Deni on
the road next week to New York City
we're cooking up some special stuff for
you guys as we get closer to our 100th
episode so ring the bell on this
playlist so you don't miss any and I'll
see you guys on Monday from the Big
Apple have a great weekend gotta go